China erprobt seit September 2021 einen
neuen atomreaktortyp so heißt es von der
Regierung ein Reaktor der Stadt mit Uran
mit Thorium betrieben werden soll und
auch Indien setzt immer mehr auf das
Konzept des Thorium Reaktors diese neue
Methode soll sicherer sein mit ihr kann
man keine Atomwaffen machen so heißt es
und sie soll die Kernkraft in ein neues
Zeitalter führen doch was ist dran an
dem ganzen genau darum geht's jetzt
[Musik]
so im Kasten nächste nothing
lasst uns erstmal klären was ist Thorium
eigentlich benannt wurde es nach dem
germanischen Gott des Donners Thorium
ist das 90 Element im Periodensystem und
wie Uran gehört es zur Gruppe der
Actinoide also zu den eher schwereren
und radioaktiven Elementen wie kann man
jetzt daraus Energie generieren nun
erstmal ist es wichtig zu betonen dass
es nicht den einen Thorium Reaktor gibt
stattdessen kann Thorium in
verschiedenen reaktor-typen verwendet
werden die meist verwendeten
Reaktortypen werden mit Wasser oder
schwerem Wasser gekühlt bei diesem Typ
wird das torium in klassischen
Brennstäben verwendet und so in den
Reaktorkern eingelassen und natürlich
wie sollte es anders sein gibt es auch
hier super viele verschiedene Typen
deswegen schauen wir uns jetzt mal
beispielhaft den Single Fluid Reaktor an
bei diesem Typ gibt es keine Brennstäbe
an sich stattdessen befindet sich das
radioaktive Material in einer Salzlösung
und fließt so durch den Reaktorkern und
den Wärmetauscher die Hal Zeit also die
Zeitspanne in der die Menge von Thorium
durch radioaktiven Zerfall auf die
Hälfte gesunken ist liegt bei Thorium
232 bei 14 Milliarden Jahren das
bedeutet dass es quasi kaum auf
natürlichem Wege zerfällt das ist
problematisch für einen Atomreaktor da
dieser durch Zerfälle betrieben wird um
Thorium spaltbar zu machen muss es also
mit Neutronen beschossen werden okay wir
benötigen einen Neutronenquelle um die
gesamte Reaktion zu starten das könnte
also irgendein Stoff sein der radioaktiv
zerfällt und dabei Neutronen freisetzt
zum Beispiel Uran 233 und da sind wir
auch gleich bei der eigentlichen
Zerfallsreihe Thorium selbst ist wie
gesagt kein spaltbares Material weshalb
man es zu einem spaltbaren umwandeln
muss das ganze nennt sich brüten
unser Thorium 232 fängt also ein Neutron
ein und wandelt sich zu Thorium 233
welches mit einer Halbwertszeit von
ungefähr 22 Minuten über einen Beta
Zerfall zerfällt dabei wandelt sich ein
Neutron im Kern in ein Proton um und das
Element protectinium 233 entsteht pro
tagtimium 233 zerfällt dann mit einer
Halbwertszeit von ungefähr 27 Tagen
wieder über einen Beta Zerfall zu Uran
233 und dieses Uran ist dann unser
eigentliches spaltbares Material das
Uran 233 muss nun ein Neutron einfangen
welches dann zu einer Spaltung führt
diese setzt dann im Durchschnitt 2,48
Neutronen frei okay klingt jetzt erstmal
seltsam aber diese Zahl kommt daher dass
es mehrere Möglichkeiten für Uran 233
gibt über Neutronen einfangen zu
reagieren solange man aber im Schnitt
mehr Neutronen produziert als man
verbraucht oder durch Verluste verloren
gehen läuft der Reaktor und ab diesem
Punkt muss Faktor nur noch mit Thorium
versorgt werden die frei gewordene
Neutronen fliegen dann zur Moderator in
unserem Fall Graphit damit sie
abgebremst werden das Tor im 232 und
auch das Uran 233 absorbieren nämlich
eher langsame Neutronen die frei
gewordene Wärmeenergie aus der Spaltung
von Uran schmilzt das trägersalz und
dieses transportiert dann in flüssigem
Zustand die Wärme zu einem Wärmetauscher
der sie wiederum an Wasser abgibt dass
eine Turbine antreibt das wiederum
elektrischen Strom erzeugt okay das
klingt ja alles sehr vielversprechend
aber welche Vorteile bietet uns denn
jetzt so ein thoriumbetriebener Reaktor
überhaupt
ein Vorteil ist dass sich der Reaktor
quasi selbst regulieren kann der Spalt
Reaktor kann nur starten wenn die
Neutronen vom Moderator abgebremst
werden schnelle Neutronen können kaum
absorbiert werden weshalb die Reaktion
allein im Reaktorkern bei den
graphitstäben passieren kann ebenso gibt
es eine weitere Sicherheitsstufe wenn
die reaktorflüssigkeit zu wird schmilzt
eine Art Salz Pfropf am Boden des
reaktorgefäßes und die Flüssigkeit
fließt in einen Auffangbehälter
unterhalb wo die Kettenreaktion zum
Stillstand kommt und das Gemisch abkühlt
ein weiterer Punkt ist dass sich die
Flüssigkeiten bei Hitze ausdehnen und
dadurch weniger Atome pro Volumen
vorhanden sind durch weniger Atome
können sich auch weniger provolumen
Spalten was wiederum zu weniger
Hitzeentwicklung führt und zu einer
Abkühlung beiträgt ein
flüssigsalzreaktor muss außerdem nicht
unter Druck stehen wie viele
uran-reaktoren die es heutzutage gibt
stattdessen werden sie unter
Atmosphärendruck betrieben das bietet
zusätzliche Sicherheit eine endgültige
Einordnung der Sicherheit des Reaktors
wird aber erst mit der Veröffentlichung
der Ergebnisse aus China möglich sein
moin Freunde Odin sei Dank muss ich mir
über die ganze Energieproblematik zum
Gewitter erzeugen keine Gedanken mehr
machen dafür habe ich jetzt einen
riesigen Solarpark der das ganze Jahr
über genug Strom erzeugt hier auf der
Spitze von hydrasil scheint ja zum Glück
war die Sonne jetzt kann ich mich in
Ruhe dem widmen was ich sowieso schon
immer am liebsten gemacht habe Kritiken
über Superhelden Filme und Serien im
Internet schreiben leider hat odin ist
aber bisher noch nicht geschafft mit
Glasfaser bis nach Asgar zu verlegen
deshalb bin ich hauptsächlich auf
offenes WLAN von euch angewiesen bei
sowas besteht aber immer die Gefahr
Opfer von man in the middle attacks zu
werden ob Loki da was mit zu tun hat
dabei geben sich Kriminelle als offenes
WLAN aus und anstatt mit dem WLAN
connecte ich mich dann mit dem Gerät der
Hacker tja und die können dann im
schlimmsten Fall meine Login-Daten
abrufen weil ich ständig verdusselt
darauf zu achten dass die URL-Zeile
https hat oder dass ein kleines Schloss
zu sehen ist nutze ich mittlerweile
einfach Nord VPN dadurch sind meine
Daten dauerhaft verschlüsselt und ich
muss mich nicht mehr mit nervigem
geoblocking rumschlagen um mir aus
Recherche Gründen alle Filme reinziehen
zu können achso nordvpn kostet im Monat
übrigens nur etwa so wie ein bechamed
oder eine Tasse Kaffee
es gibt eine 30 Tage Geld zurück
Garantie und wenn ihr direkt ein
Zweijahresabo abschließt bekommt ihr mit
dem Code dr Watson 4 Monate gratis und
jetzt zurück an die Arbeit Loki starke
Bilder leider einen außergewöhnlich
schwacher Charakter zwei von zehn
hämmern
ein weiteres Argument im Bereich der
Sicherheit wird auch oft aufgeführt
nämlich dass aus Thorium betriebenen
Reaktoren keine Atomwaffen hergestellt
werden können jedoch greift dieses
Argument nicht so gut da nicht die Frage
ist ob man Waffen daraus herstellen kann
sondern wie leicht man es kann klar
stimmt es dass das Uran 233 nicht
verwendbar ist da ist durch das
gammastrahlende Uran 232 verunreinigt
ist jedoch reicht schon eine kleine
nukleareinrichtung aus um über Umwege
aus Thorium waffenfähiges Uran 233
herzustellen
okay aber es gibt noch andere Argumente
Thorium würde manchen Ländern eine
geostrategische Unabhängigkeit im
Energiesektor gewährleisten größere
Vorkommen wurden bislang in China
Australien Brasilien der Türkei Norwegen
Indien und den USA entdeckt dadurch
haben diese Länder die Möglichkeit in
ihrer Energieversorgung unabhängiger zu
werden und so von politischen Sanktionen
weniger betroffen zu sein fast das
gesamte Thorium in der Natur ist nämlich
Thorium 232 was die Handhabung etwas
erleichtert durch die charakteristische
Zerfallskette werden bei diesem
Reaktortyp auch Neutronen besser
verwertet das heißt die eingefangenen
Neutronen bewirken statistisch mehr
Spaltungen und werden nicht einfach nur
absorbiert und gehen dadurch verloren
in der Zerfallsreihe ist ebenso die
Produktion von Plutonium und anderen
schweren Elementen sehr abgemildert was
ein geringeres Gesundheitsrisiko und
langfristig weniger Atommüll bedeutet
die meisten radioaktiven Abfälle im
Thorium Uran brutkreislauf haben im
Vergleich zu herkömmlichen Kreisläufen
eine kurze Halbwertszeit wir sprechen
hier von einer Verkürzung von 100.000
Jahren auf 300 bis 500 Jahre bei einem
thorium-reaktor wird außerdem quasi der
gesamte Brennstoff also das Thorium und
das Uran 233 umgewandelt um Energie zu
erzeugen bei bisher genutzten Reaktoren
bestehen nur ungefähr 4% aus dem
spaltbaren Uran 235 die restlichen 96%
sind kontaminiertes Uran 238 welches
nicht spaltbar ist aber gleichzeitig
Neutronen absorbiert so dass die
uranbrennstäbe alle zwei Jahre
ausgewechselt werden müssen und wiederum
mehr Müll entsteht oft wird auch davon
gesprochen dass mit Thorium Reaktoren
Atommüll recycelt werden kann dadurch
bewirkt wird dass dieser weniger lange
strahlt das ist natürlich eine gute
Sache hier muss man aber eindeutig die
verschiedenen Reaktortypen unterscheiden
in China wird momentan ein thermischer
Thorium Reaktor gebaut um Thorium als
Brennstoff zu erproben für das Recycling
benötigt man aber eher schnelle
Neutronen Reaktortypen die schwere stark
strahlende Elemente unschädlicher machen
die gibt es bereits und diese sind auch
schon im Einsatz jedoch tatsächlich
nicht mit Thorium sondern ganz normal
mit Uran falls wir dazu noch mal ein
extra Video machen sollen also wie man
quasi mit Kernkraft aus der Kernkraft
und dem verbundenen Atommüll aussteigen
kann dann schreibt mir das gerne mal
unten in die Kommentare wir machen gerne
ein Video dazu okay cool wieso bauen wir
nicht also einfach ganz viele Thorium
Reaktoren wenn die doch alle so toll
sein sollen gut es ist Zeit kommen wir
mal zu den Nachteilen des neuen
Reaktortyps zum einen Thorium Reaktoren
stecken noch in der Forschung und sind
gerade noch gar nicht bereit kommerziell
gebaut zu werden und selbst wenn sie das
wären würden sie in der aktuellen
Energiekrise überhaupt nicht helfen neue
Kernkraftwerke inklusive Planung Bau und
Inbetriebnahme können gut und gerne mal
15 Jahre und länger benötigen außerdem
bei Thorium Reaktoren haben wir zwar
weniger Atommüll in der Menge jedoch
strahlt dieser Müll anders insbesondere
die Entstehung des nebenprodukts Tritium
im Reaktor verlangt eine spezielle
Handhabung Tritium ist ein radioaktives
Wasserstoff Isotop das in relevanten
Mengen im Reaktor als Spaltprodukt
entsteht bei hohen Temperaturen kann
Tritium Metallwände durchdringen weshalb
es aufgefangen und isoliert werden muss
das ist aber bei der Menge an Tritium
teuer und tatsächlich gar nicht so
einfach ein anderes Problem die
Zerfallskette vom Endprodukt Uran 232
mit einer Halbwertszeit von knapp 70
Jahren erzeugt sehr hoch energetische
gamastrahlen weshalb der entstehende
Müll daraus gekühlt werden müsste das
macht Abfall aus thorium-reaktoren in
den ersten lagerungsjahren um einiges
anspruchsvoller als der herkömmliche
Müll von uran-reaktoren eine Lösung das
Nachteils wäre die Verwendung eines
alternativen thermodynamischen
Kreisprozesses an dem jedoch noch
geforscht werden muss eines der größten
Probleme ist aber die Korrosion im
Reaktor wenn Neutronen mit dem Material
der Reaktorwand in Kontakt treten bilden
sich Gase die das Material der Wand
spröde machen ebenso belasten einige
Spaltprodukte die Reaktorwand und
verursachen Korrosion es gibt zwar
bereits erste Ansätze dieses Problem in
Angriff zu nehmen jedoch noch keine
veröffentlichten Durchbrüche in der
Materialforschung in China wird
anscheinend momentan mit Kohlenstoff und
einer besonderen Art von keramikmatrix
Verbundwerkstoffen gearbeitet die
Temperaturen bis zu 1.000°c aushalten
können manche werden nun vielleicht
sagen mir noch egal ob Vor oder
Nachteile sicher oder nicht Kernkraft
ist echt einfach zu teuer und es gibt
günstigere Alternativen in den letzten
Jahren sind nämlich die Kosten von
solar- und Windenergie stetig gesunken
günstigere Alternativen von Kernkraft
wurden aber noch nicht kommerzialisiert
warum existiert darf dann überhaupt noch
naja Kernkraft bietet eine wetter- und
standortunabhängige Energiequelle mit
geringem Flächen Verbrauch Energie von
Kernkraftwerken ist immer da die von
erneuerbaren nur wenn die Sonne scheint
oder der Wind wählt und die Flächen die
erneuerbare Energien benötigen stoßen in
der Bevölkerung auf vergleichsweise
großen Widerstand der globale
Stromverbrauch soll sich bis 2050
verdreifachen und die Kernenergie deckt
heute mit nur 440 Reaktoren etwa 10% der
Welt Energie außerdem gibt Kernenergie
keine schädlichen Emissionen in die Luft
ab im Gegensatz zu fossilen Brennstoffen
was zu vielen Gesundheitsproblemen und
Todesfällen führt und Kernenergie hat
einen extrem niedrigen CO2-Fußabdruck
man sollte an dieser Stelle natürlich
betonen dass weder Kernkraft noch
Photovoltaik oder Windkraftanlagen zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt in ihrer Gesamtheit
klimaneutral sind aber im Vergleich zu
fossilen Energieträgern sind sie
eindeutig die bessere Option dennoch und
achtung jetzt kommt meine eigene Meinung
glaube ich nicht dass wir für unsere
Energieversorgung der Zukunft auf Kern
setzen sollten Sie ist zu teuer zu
langsam zu gefährlich und zu blockieren
das jetzt noch weiter auszuführen würde
hier den Rahmen sprengen und ist auch
gar nicht das Thema dieses Videos hier
aber Mai hat das in ihrer Folge my
thinkx zu diesem Thema sehr gut erklärt
ich habe sie euch mal unten in der
Videobeschreibung verlinkt und ich war
übrigens da auch im Publikum ich bin mal
sehr gespannt ob ihr mich da entdecken
könnt als allerletzten Punkt ist
trotzdem noch interessant dass egal wie
man zu Kernkraftwerken steht die
Forschung in diesem Bereich sehr wichtig
für unsere Gesellschaft ist es ist
nämlich nicht nur die Energieerzeugung
die wir hier erhalten beispielsweise
benötigt man Reaktoren auch zur
Gewinnung von Neutronen worauf die
moderne Medizin angewiesen ist in der
Tumortherapie und auch beispielsweise in
der Entwicklung von Impfstoffen oder bei
der Analyse von Werkstoffen sind die vom
Reaktor produzierten Neutronen
essentiell
ein reines Schwarz-Weiß-Denken ist
generell aber vor allem in diesem
Bereich also überhaupt nicht sinnvoll
deswegen bleibt offen für neue Forschung
und bleibt wie immer neugierig euer
Cedric